[Music]
hello good morning ladies and gentlemen
my name is Mohan Krishnan I am the CTO
at bbm today I want to share with you
guys a story about how we migrated the
bbm uses and this is the what was
originally known as the blackberry
messenger from our Canadian data center
on Prem to Google Cloud
before starting though I'd like to ask
maybe you guys a couple of questions
firstly how many of y'all are
considering doing a migration from on
Prem to the cloud in maybe the next six
to nine months show of hands
okay great so hopefully this content is
relevant for your the next question how
many of you all know what bbm is okay
keep your hands up how many of you all
know that bbm is today available on
Android and iOS and continuously being
improved great so you guys know that our
story that's awesome thank you very much
let's go so let's start what I'd like to
start with is a bit of background
because I get lots of questions as to
what's going on with bbm what's
happening so this is just to set things
up a bit I work for a company called M
Tech M Tech is Indonesia's largest media
conglomerate we own TV stations both
paid on free-to-air national TV stations
we own production houses and been in the
media business for about five to ten
years in about the last two to three
years we've also been going online
primarily again taking our content from
traditional media to online so we run
today Indonesia's largest online news
portals similar like Conde Ness but for
the Internet we also run Indonesia's
second largest video platform we only
second to YouTube today our content and
our services touch over 50 to 60 million
monthly active users in Indonesia as
part of that strategy of growing that
side of the business
we decided that besides just being a con
and producer we also wanted to be a
platform a platform for people to come
and consume our content to that goal we
found that in Indonesia there's still a
large amount of bbm users compared to
the rest of the world and we then engage
with blackberry to wholly license so
we've acquired a license from blackberry
for bbm for the consumer business so
today since 2016 when the agreement was
signed we build develop and distribute
bbm for the consumer market a key part
of achieving our goals around that was
migrating bbm and I'm going to get into
the specifics around that in a bit but
I'd like to share how large from a human
person standpoint this project was it
spanned about two years we officially
only finished in June 2018 it involved
anywhere between 40 to 60 engineers span
across 12-hour time zones across three
different countries Canada Singapore and
Jakarta the next thing I want to share
with you guys before we get into the
specifics is that this is not your
father's bbm anymore many people still
think that bbm is only available on BB
iOS and BB 10 devices
this is bbm for Android and iOS modern
operating systems apart from that this
is also a bbm that is on par with your
modern Facebook messengers and whatsapp
this includes things like video and
voice calling large groups availability
on multiple platforms including desktop
and more importantly what we've been
focused on and why we made this
transition is we are building features
for our market how many of you all are
familiar with WeChat so okay we chat you
guys know that story it's huge in China
and the reason why it's huge also is
because it's a messenger that's focused
for that market that's exactly what
we're doing we're trying to make bbm the
WeChat of Indonesia to that goal we've
been building features like wallet so
today if you use bbm Indonesia you can
send money to each other you can make
transactions you can buy things like
internet top
so your phone pay your phone bills apart
from that we've also been integrating
bbm into the local phone systems in the
next two months we'll be rolling out a
feature where you can make PSTN calls
and receive calls via a number that is a
side to your bbm so when you register
for bbm in Indonesia you get a local
phone number and you can use it this is
extremely relevant for the market that
we operate where there's still many
users who are rural areas with very poor
data connectivity they can still keep in
touch by piggybacking on the PSTN
network to contact their friends and
family on bbm so in a nutshell what was
the transition so it involves moving the
bbm infrastructure footprint from Canada
all the way to GCP in the Asian region
it also so what and why did we do this
well first and foremost as you guys
probably know bbm as a globe the global
use of ways for bbm has reduced but it's
still a sizable user base in Asia
primarily in Indonesia in Africa and in
the Middle East we wanted to bring the
bbm services closer to our users our
this will improve latency you would also
improve network reliability that was the
first goal but a second major driving
goal was Reap lat forming bbm on cloud
infrastructure that allow us to build
the type of features that I was talking
about earlier and a fast and effective
manner that was a huge goal lastly it's
important to keep in mind that during
the entire one and a half years that we
were doing this transition we still had
billions of messengers and tens of
millions of users using the platform
without any problem we were migrating
them in the background without them
realizing and not impacting their
service also during these 18 months we
continued to push out new and exciting
features for user base so what was it
that we migrated I know there are some
ex blackberry people in the audience
today so these guys are probably
familiar with it but bbm was
a simple simple application to my grade
it consisted of over between 20 major
components each of these components had
multiple sub components you look at it
and you go and you might go wow it looks
like a microservices Architecture from
our end I think it was an accidental
micro service architecture it was a
amalgamation of different components
built over a ten to three year time line
from different teams using different
technologies and frameworks that are
available at that point that added a lot
of complexity we had everything from
JBoss different versions of spring
custom Java frameworks that we had to
rationalize and plan how we were going
to deploy and run in GCP apart from that
it was a sizable infrastructure
footprint over 14,000 VMs on physical
machines running in blackberries data
centers in Canada NetApp
appliances fusion I of fiber base
storage large data analytics and Hadoop
clusters and also an assortment of
databases it had a 600 had to migrate a
600 node Cassandra cluster multiple
MySQL 4n Postgres databases as well so
it was a large a large piece of
infrastructure to move this diagram here
is mostly for short factor don't don't
look at it too hard but this is an
attempt at trying to map out all the
different components that made up bbm
and their interconnection as you can see
the summary is it wasn't a simple system
neatly compat mentalizing two logical
components that it was not so how did we
do the migration what did it involve
there were three major parts or tasks
that we had to go through firstly was
the preparation and I'll talk about that
in a bit secondly we mapped out the
different services that were running and
how they would end up running in GCP and
lastly was the actual traffic cut over
and I'll go to that one by
what we were trying to answer in
preparation was what is there to move
and where do we move it to why the
reason why we had this question of what
is there to move was
keep in mind that the team that was
going to do this migration for the most
part did not build and did not operate
this service
they didn't have any idea as to what was
running so we had to go through a
process of trying to inventory the
service and understand what was there
first from an inventory standpoint there
were two major aspects firstly was just
mapping out the individual services
whereas the source code for the service
how do you build it what are the Jenkins
pipelines what are the dependencies what
are the configurations that we need to
pull in each component had anywhere
between four to five hundred different
configurations many at times there were
configurations where people didn't
understand it's just been that way for
multiple years and we had to do a lot of
so-called archeology to try to figure
out and put the pieces together the
second part of the inventory was from an
Operations standpoint how did these
services run in their current on-prem
infrastructure what were the type of
servers that were required to run these
services what were the type of metrics
and alerting that was used to make sure
that the services were healthy what type
of log output did they produce which
compartes of the log were relevant from
an operational standpoint and lastly
even bandwidth utilization because we
were moving to a model where egress
bandwidth was going to be meted as
opposed to a typical on-prem setup where
you don't you don't you buy the bulk top
peak bandwidth throughput that you need
so we had to map that out and figure it
out what worked really well for us from
a service standpoint of trying to figure
out how the service ran is that we
documented everything in code we didn't
just write it all down we actually had
our developers work out right ansible
playbooks to get this all set up and
they made sure that the services at
least stood up within a vagrant box that
gave us the assuredness that this
information was documented from an
Operations
TenPoint what we did was we created this
giant spreadsheets as you can see here
again don't look at it too hard but
essentially it mapped out all different
aspects of the service and how it ran in
production the next step was actually
deciding where we were going to go it
wasn't a slam dunk that we were moving
to GCP we actually ran PLC's with three
different cloud vendors
I'm sure Tim and some of the guys from
Google in the crowd still remember this
we ran two to four week Piercy's on-site
with blackberry where we try where what
we did was we try to put one two key
services into the cloud and then
actually load tested in there see how it
worked this gave us two things firstly
it helped us further understand these
individual services because we were also
still figuring it out and secondly it
gave us a lot more clarity as to how
these services were running within GC
within the individual cloud providers in
the end we did an evaluation we
evaluated on three major Krait criteria
the technical capabilities of the cloud
provider its partner support and costs
and goes without saying I'm here next
and GC PE was the winner and we've been
happy with the decision since you know
we've been happy with the decision it's
really worked out for us from a partner
standpoint as well we worked with some
really great partners like Pythian and
cloud cover but also in the room here
today and that really really got us over
the line the table on the right here
shows some like in a condensed form the
different aspects of the comparison
there were a lot more details I can get
to specifics if you guys want but it was
a long process by the time we were done
with this phase in venturing the system
and picking the cloud vendor we were
four months into this project already so
now that we know what we want to migrate
we know where we're going to migrate to
the next step was to really figure out
how are we going to have these
components run in the cloud and the
first question and I've seen this
question you know being repeated through
conversations that I've had with other
people who have gone through migration
and I'm sure some of you guys who are
considering migration now I had
this exact is heavy are having this
exact question is do we just live and
shift the services as is or do we use
this as an opportunity to re-engineer it
re-platform it on something new now
intuitively lifting and shifting makes
sense you minimize risk already making
this major change why change the
application at the same time
why increase the complexity but the
challenge with services that were
originally built for on Prem
infrastructure I believe is that
sometimes there's certain aspects or
certain operational aspects of those
services that rely on very specific on
Prem characteristics trying to replicate
this on Prem characteristics in the
cloud cloud end up adding risk to your
project so I don't think it's a done
deal
I don't think anybody who's making a
large migration a complex enough
migration is ever going to have purely a
lift and shift or a reap lat form
re-engineer it's going to be a spectrum
a hybrid approach and for us that's
exactly what happened there were certain
characteristics of components that when
we saw we realized that we'd have to
re-engineer the first being applications
that relied on file storage so this were
applications that wrote to disk and you
know either the sand disks or net apps
we realized early on that there was a
great opportunity to move this to cloud
storage which was more suited for object
storage now making this change was a lot
of work it involves a lot of change we
practically rewrote these components
however what we realized in rewriting
them is not existing complexity within
these applications for example to handle
sharding between multiple file endpoints
or to handle failures that only happen
within file systems we could remove and
it actually greatly simplified these
applications yes we had to introduce
special code to handle the fact that now
your rights are have much higher latency
because they're going over HTTP but in
the end we felt a trade-off made sense
the other two areas where re-engineering
made complete sense and was a no-brainer
was on our log
inside of components and data
engineering I'll go into that specifics
in a bit so if you look at all those
different components you know I said
they were like you know almost 20
different components and multiple sub
components what I'm trying to what I'm
going to try to do today for you is that
you know digest it all and talk about
these different components or sub
components within this different level
so networking applies for all the
components that we're talking about
let's start on a networking side on Prem
what we were running were a lot of f5
load balancers how many of you all have
f5 load balancers in your data centers
today ok as you guys probably know those
things are great workhorses they're
extremely reliable they are extremely
flexible
you're not going to surf that same level
of flexibility in the cloud and it was
that was one of the gaps that we had to
deal with early on within our own Prem
datacenter the f5 l TMS were used for
both external and internal load
balancing they were also used for NAT so
how did we migrate this existing
functionality to GCP we essentially
ended up using every type of load
balancer that's available in GCP we use
the network load balancer the TCP proxy
load balancer HTP load bounces and the
internal load bouncer and I'll go
through why we ended up needing to use
every single load balancer in a bit the
other aspect was NAT there was no
immediate NAT solution available manage
NAT is still not available within GCP
today at least I don't think it is or
maybe it's just coming out two years ago
when we were started it was not
available yet so we ended up deploying
our own man NAT solution we ensured it's
hichy the good thing today is if you
Google you'll find several best practice
references on how to set something like
this up this is a solve problem but you
have to row at least we had to roll our
own back then and back then we weren't
entirely sure how to make sure that was
hey CheY so way to figure that out other
got just that stuck out when we were
doing the networking piece the first was
multicast again if you're in Prem
you don't have and run a physical
networking you know you're not gonna
have problems with having multicast
multicast is not available on any cloud
provider and we had components that
relied on multicast in particular some
of our Java applications use this grid
caching technology called in finish man
the good news there is changing in
finish banned from using multicast to
using other type of drivers we ended up
using TCP ping it's pretty
straightforward
so we had to make that change the other
thing to be aware of especially if you
have a large footprint is that there is
a maximum cap on the total amount of IPs
that you can have within a network and
this catches big deployments off when we
were doing this we had a maximum of
seven thousand IPs and this led to a lot
of sleepless nights I was trying to work
things out the good news is by the time
we actually went to production Google
upgraded its network and now today they
support up to 15,000 IPs and our 6000
odd infrastructure footprint fit within
it the other gotcha was around load
balancers and this is why we ended up
having multiple load bounces the first
gotcha was we had a service that was
serving an endpoint publicly on port
5:06 one the TCP load balancer supports
a specific list of ports they're about
12 ports at its support if you don't
happen to if you have existing clients
or services that rely on these parts
without changing it you're dead in the
water you cannot serve from it so that's
why we had to replace it with a network
load balancer which didn't have this
limitation so now we have NLB secondly
we had services with TLS endpoints where
the clients were doing mutual TLS so we
couldn't rely again on http load
balancers where TLS was being terminated
on the load bouncer we ended up solving
this by using TCP load balancers and
doing mutual TLS on the instance itself
then we had a class of applications with
our bog standard hitch Pisa HTTP
endpoints and we could serve them
through the HP load balancers so these
are some of the limitations and again
you know you
you look at what's out here you look at
Kerber annuities and all these cool
standard stuff but we don't have that
luxury when you're moving existing
infrastructure and finding this type of
problems early and designing for it is
critical on the storage side the story
was a bit more simpler the good news
that the summary or the upshot was for
the most part where it came the
performance of Google's GCS and PD SSD
disks surpassed what we were having
running in our data center we had NetApp
appliances and we had San arrays built
off SSDs and bored PD SSD and GCS was a
good fit and replacement for what was
running there now we get into the data
base and caching side of things the
first database that we had to deal with
were around we had a large Oracle
deployment now as some of y'all might
know if you've dug into this Oracle is
thought you know sanctioned to run on
GCP neither did we want to pay any Larry
Ellison tax we think his yachts are
large enough so not only did we have to
plan to migrate the database we had to
plan to transform the database off
Oracle to Postgres before actually
rolling it out or migrating it to GCP so
we planned it in and got that done let's
say when he came to some of those my
sequel databases we just targeted cloud
SQL as score SQL was reasonably mature
by that point and not many of this
database was super critical for
production running of our app for
Cassandra a lot of time was spent trying
to size the instances that we're going
to run the Cassandra nodes so figuring
out from a you know CPU Ram we end up
using PD SSD turned out those were fast
enough our use case we also spend a lot
of time working out the operational
aspects of it building playbooks
understanding how we were going to do
rolling updates dealing with downloads
all that had to be set up and we set up
a special team within our group to
handle that they got most of the setup
within two to three months but that was
a big investment
ready send memcache we started out
setting these up on our own doing
something similar to Cassandra but then
we found a partner even and they are
pretty competent I would strongly
recommend them if you're looking at
trying to set up something similar at
that point memory store wasn't available
we hope going forward we can look at
memory store as a replacement for third
party services from even net net we end
up with about 400 nodes of Cassandra
nodes a host of my sequel Postgres and
memcache instances the next portion was
monitoring and this is where God
interesting what we had originally on
on-prem was a large CA Wylie deployment
capturing hundreds or thousands of JMX
metrics from each instance all of this
was then graphed on graph on a-- and
alerting was done through na jos now
when we first looked at that our natural
inclination was you know what let's move
all of this to stackdriver that makes
sense it's provided in wool cloud why
wouldn't we leverage it turns out there
was a big mismatch at least at that
point two years ago with getting JMX
metrics especially the vast amount of
gmx metrics that our services were using
into stackdriver
it was non-trivial we would end up
needing to write lots of scripts
manually listing out the gmx metrics it
wouldn't scale the second x fact that we
found stackdriver suffered with was just
around the sheer size of our
dashboarding the stackdriver dashboards
back then I haven't looked at it lately
so you know don't get upset with me but
they just weren't going to cut it there
were underperforming they frequently
just got they hung the amount of
analytics that you could do on it was
very poor so we ended up going with data
dog and that's worked out quite well for
us
so what we have today is a set up that
looks similar to this
we export their certain metrics they
don't come from the instance like GL B
matrix you know metrics from your
managed services from your networking
from your Software Defined now
King those we export from stackdriver to
Dana dog apart from that we run the data
dog agent on our instances and that also
pushes metrics to the era of bedrock
then functions as system to collect our
metrics as well for us to build handle
alerting on it these then become
available as dashboards which our ops
team and our developers use as well as
for incident management trough Seany it
worked out quite well for the most part
today we have over 6,000 hosts running
in this manner and over 250,000 metrics
running on daily dog so it's quite
scalable there are a couple of gotchas
worth considering firstly is there was a
lag between capturing the stack travel
metrics to Dana dog now I don't know if
they were just trying to throw a spanner
into that integration just kidding but
it was delayed and initially it was
unusable there was a six minute delay
between something happening on the load
balancers and it being available to
daily dog we worked with Google and data
dog to get that solved today the delay
is about a minute or less but there's
still a delay and we continue to work
with them on it if you guys are looking
at a similar integration do push them
along it'll benefit all of us
the other thing what considering is that
data dog is not available within the GCP
infrastructure at least when we rolled
it out it was hosted on AWS which meant
that you're going to have a fair bit of
egress going out or from your nodes
especially if you have a large enough
footprint like ours going to data dog
data centers which I think now a SS in
Europe and in u.s. East however the good
news day is the latency is introduced by
that wasn't too damaging for the most
part the dashboards and the alerting and
the metrics all being captured in
reasonable amount of time and it's
working okay for us the next expec was
around logging ok and what we had
running on Prem was we'd have instances
running a Kafka client that also doubled
up as a syslog agent so applications
would just log as though they are
logging to syslog it would then get
picked up by kafka client we should
then push it to a Kafka broker and the
Kafka broker then had a bunch of workers
picking off the logs and writing it to a
Hadoop file system this mostly worked
but what it meant is that to query these
logs users would need to spin up Hadoop
jobs and basically do a MapReduce to
find logs this one this was a bit slow
and painful so we wanted to re-engineer
it we didn't want to just have this
coming along secondly also especially if
you re platforming on GCP the tons of
build services like part cloud pub/sub
and dataflow that makes sense to solve
this problem and that's what we ended up
with so what we ended up with is we ran
the standard flu and D agent on the
instances this flu and the agent acts as
a local our syslog daemon so again you
can have those applications as the you
know just log as though they are writing
to syslog it then gets pushed to cloud
pub/sub which then gets picked up by
data flow and then dataflow writes to
two endpoints it writes to elasticsearch
and it's accessible to our team through
Cubana and it also writes avro files to
GCS and it's accessible to our teams for
Zeppelin the use cases for elastic
search and how Zeppelin Cabana is
different elastic search allows our
users especially our operational team or
the developers working on the services
to access these logs pretty quickly and
easily through some search queries but
we can't we try to from fork from a cost
standpoint we try to keep our elastic
search cluster maintained at a fixed
size we don't need to continuously grow
so what that means is that we age out
logs so we keep up up to about 14 days
retention within our elastic search
clusters but within GCS we store those
logs now for perpetuity but what it
means is that to access data from that
it's a bit more tedious and you go
through we provide Zeppelin as a
front-end for it and it mostly works it
also serves as the input for a lot of
our data analytics and data engineering
jobs which is what I'll talk about now
so on a big data standpoint as I
mentioned earlier we had raw data in
Hadoop FS we had a
on-prem we had a large hive based data
warehouse we were managing these data
engineering jobs using easy and click
view for dashboarding this entire stack
was Reap lat formed we replaced kuzey
with airflow for job management we
replaced all our hive data with Spock
so and which would feed off GCS so the
logs that we had ingested earlier we
also had events streaming coming in
through GCS and this would be picked up
by a ETL jobs running on apache spark
this apache spark cluster would also
write back to GCS where necessary and
for for our data science and data
engineering work we would use park'
files we would also sometimes for
primarily for business analysts and for
business reporting run ETL jobs and
write it straight to bigquery and then
we would have tableau run queries
against our bigquery instance so this
allowed us to in some cases have you
know when you have clear business
reports that are clearly defined and not
going to change too much
we have ETL jobs right to bigquery and
make them queryable extremely quickly in
cases where we want to provide more ad
hoc analytics we provided that true
Zeppelin running over pocket files
within GCS this as well has worked quite
well for us we migrated over 100 ETL
jobs that today run over 18,000 V CPUs
we process 20 terabytes of data a day
and these jobs on average run between
one to two hours max in the past when we
were running on Prem this jobs would
take sometimes up to two days so this
has been a huge improvement for the
business and finally at the top of the
stack is our application service and for
this when we looked at what was running
initially we saw a combination of over
15 different type of CPU RAM disk
combinations we tried initially trying
to streamline this migrating what we had
but what we found in the end is that at
least for our use cases the comp the
configurations that were running on Prem
when
the configurations that we ended up
running in the cloud in retrospect it
seems obvious because we try to order
scale some of these instances what we
could end up with which we generally
ended up reducing the size the footprint
of these individual instances so that we
could scale them up and down easily so
my suggestion here the takeaway here
would be don't waste too much time
trying to do this especially if you're
coming from an on-prem environment just
get to the point that you can test this
and figure it out as you go along how
you do that is what I'm going to touch
on a bit later so we've just finished
the whirlwind you know plan of trying to
figure out how we're going to
re-engineer what we're going to
reengineer how we're gonna run that that
now again took us about two months plus
sitting in you know windowless meeting
rooms working together with partners
like Pythian and cloud cover and our
engineering team and getting all that
bashed out testing some of the
assumptions but now that we had figured
it out the next step was to actually
build a service up now that we know what
we want to go how do we get running the
first thing that we did before actually
coming up with a plan was and this was
actually done quite early in our
transition plan is that we started with
some guiding principles as to how we
were going to do traffic cutter work and
again I think this is a takeaway for
teams you need to sit with your business
and figure out what is acceptable to
them from our end because we are a
real-time messaging system with tens of
millions of users it was decided that we
cannot afford to have any downtime for
users I put an asterisk there and I'll
come back to it in a bit but we didn't
want to have any downtime for users we
couldn't afford that what that meant
though is that from a planning
standpoint from a timeline standpoint we
buffered things we stretch things out we
ensured that we had enough time to do
the engineering which is why it took two
years in the end there is definitely
going to be a trade-off in terms of how
much downtime you are willing to take
and how much time the overall transition
is going to take that you need to figure
out yourself but do consider this the
second thing that we knew from the
get-go is that we wanted to allow for
learning through the transition process
through the traffic control process
because as I mentioned earlier for the
most part this was a team that did not
build or operate this service before we
knew that there are lots of unknowns
unknowns and the only way to figure
these unknowns was to actually
experience it when we were running in
production how did we achieve that
retrieve that by ensuring that the
traffic cutover could be done in an
incremental fashion and I'll touch on
how we achieved that in a bit the last
thing is we wanted to be resilient to
mistakes we wanted to make sure that if
we had a problem in the traffic cut over
we didn't have to incur downtime until
the problem was fixed we needed a way
that we could send traffic back to our
on-prem DC and then ensure that services
could continue to run while we figured
out how to actually fix it in Google
Cloud so that meant no big banks we
couldn't afford that the traffic cut
over itself can be broken down to four
stages firstly we're setting up joint
networking secondly is getting a data
replicated taps of a deployment and a
client traffic cut over itself let's go
through this one thing that's really
nice about Google cloud that we leverage
was the ability to set up a dedicated
interconnect between our on-prem DC and
the data centers in Asia now because
Google has a private interconnect they
talked about it it's called a premium
network this ensured that we could set
up these networks between these theses
and they were low latency and highly
reliable we didn't have any outage any
service impacting outage during a period
every now and then we'd have some spikes
but they were mostly resolves but most
importantly the latency between our data
centers in Asia back to Canada was
between 200 250 milliseconds this meant
that we could do certain type of traffic
cut our strategies that not having this
type of latency would afford so for
example if the latencies were a lot
higher some of the database replication
techniques wouldn't work a touch on that
a bit
so because a large footprint of our data
was stored in Cassandra that goddess
replication for free
Cassandra's some of you guys probably
know has native four application built
into it so that was pretty
straightforward we spun about Cassandra
nodes let the replication run true and
we had our data in GC p when it came to
Postgres we set up master slave for
applications Alvaro is here he worked
with us on it and what we had to do in
the end to actually get the users onto
the new master was to actually do a
master promotion now this is the one
time that we had to take some downtime
when we made the master promotion we
didn't have the application service
service point to the new master and
proxy requests back from the whole
application service so there was a
minimal downtime about 5 to 10 minutes
while this process was ongoing this
didn't impact any of our key services
though messages continued to work people
could chat with each other and therefore
was seen as acceptable when it came to
caches we modified our application to be
able to do dual right so any application
that would use memcache or Redis we
introduced the ability to define more
than one cluster you write to both
clusters one cluster operating in gcpd
other on-prem and then when we finally
cut over we were both read and write
from the next cluster so we've got the
data migrated so we have the networking
set up before the data migrated the next
step was actually rolling out the app
servers now if you remember from the
start I mentioned there were many many
app servers many many services so the
first step was to really map out all the
dependencies with the application
service and pick one application server
with the least amount of dependencies we
then would take the deployment of that
application server till the end what I
mean by tilde n is we would have
production traffic working on that one
application server that one service
before moving to the next this is almost
like canary
your traffic card over it allowed us to
ensure that any type of mistakes that we
might have made with our first service
we do not repeat for subsequent services
that we were cutting over and I think
this was a bit this was very useful for
us if there were any requests
so when we move the service over to GCP
if there are any requests that were
dependent on services that weren't in
GCP yet because we're cutting one
service at a time again we would be able
to leverage the our GCP direct
interconnect to just proxy this requests
back to our on-prem data center if we
didn't have that low latency link a lot
of this type of migration techniques
wouldn't be possible once we had a
single individuals app server running in
GCP we would then cut server to server
traffic to it first and again that also
would be cut incrementally we'd have 10%
of the fleet make the requests and then
slowly bump it up more as we had more
assurance that the service was running
fine we then would repeat we then move
to the clients we would then we then
move to the client traffic cutover
how did we do this incrementally the
first step required instrumenting the
client to be able to receive service
endpoints from a third party so
basically push the service endpoints to
it the way we achieved this was
obviously we had to push out a new
version of a client that supported this
capability but we also leveraged
firebase remote config as the back-end
service to push this values or the
service endpoints to the client we could
have built our own and service to do
this but the benefit of using firebase
remote config was that it already has
internal capabilities around client
targeting that would be that proved to
be very useful and it also allows you to
roll values or key updates incrementally
so we could say one percent of the
entire client population has this new
service endpoint see how the service
performs and then slowly ramp this up
when we got to 100% we then move to the
next service so essentially that's what
it was we did service by service piece
by piece we take the learnings and then
apply to the next one Yuri please you
repeat it 20 times and you fully cut
over without your users knowing
and that's it that's how we migrated the
entire bbm service to GCP I think a
couple of key learnings that we
discovered as we went along firstly is
they are definitely going to be gorgeous
unless you're deploying a cloud native
service that was already designed for
the cloud they are got just hiding
somewhere and you need to dig them out
if you haven't found them yet it's
probably because you haven't looked hard
enough get alignment from the business
in terms of what impact they're willing
to take as part of the transition this
will really define how much effort and
time and money you're going to need to
invest in to your transition the third
aspect is and this is something that we
totally missed when we were starting out
is the communications between the
different teams involved in the
transition is going to be a single
toughest non-technical problem we were
not prepared for this this communication
can be between any group it could be
between your partner's yourself and
Jesus and Google cloud technical team or
in our case for example it was that and
also the combinatorial impact of having
teams spread across Canada Singapore and
Jakarta you multiply of this and you've
got an very n square problem on your
hand
lastly I'd say and this really worked
well for us is baking the ability to
fail you're going to be making mistakes
that's the only way you're going to get
something complex right with if you bake
it in from the start you can recover
learn and move on thank you very much
[Music]